رغم عملهما معا في مكتب بسيط للعقارات بحي
اسانيورت في اسطنبول الا ان ايدن ونوري
ليس على قلب رجل واحد فيما يخص الانتخابات
التركيه القادمه
كلاهما من اكراد تركيا لكن توجهاتهما
السياسيه التي كانت متوافقه فيما مضى
اختلفت في هذه الانتخابات
في سنوات حكمه الاولى كان الحزب الحاكم
جيدا على كافه الاصعده كثير من الاكراد
كانوا يصوتون لصالح حزب العداله والتنميه
لكن في الاونه الاخيره ولا سيما بعد
التدهور الاقتصادي اصبحت مقتنعا بضروره
التغيير لذلك لن اصوت الحزب العداله
والتنميه بل لكمالك الجدار اوغلو بان
ساصوت للرئيس اردوغان انا راضا عن سياساته
تجاه الاكراد واحبه شخصيا لذلك سامنحه
صوتي من جديد
تقدر نسبه الاكراد في تركيا بخمسه عشر في
المئه من عدد السكان واعتاد حزب العداله
والتنميه ان يكون الحزب الثاني كسبا
للاصوات في المناطق ذات الغالبيه الكرديه
خلف حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي الكردي الذي
يملك القاعده الانتخابيه الاكبر في اوساط
الاكراد لكن تضييق الذي مارسته الحكومه ضد
الحزب الكردي وسعيها لاغلاقه دفع الكثير
من الاكراد الى اعاده النظر بموقفهم
السياسي من الحزب الحاكم في البلاد
تحسبا من قرار الاغلاق قرر حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي خوض الانتخابات باسم حزب
اليسار الاخضر واسست تحالفا للاحزاب
اليساريه وهو تحالف العمل والحريه
التحالف الجديد قرر عدم اختيار مرشح
للانتخابات الرئاسيه بل قرر دعم مرشح
المعارضه كمال كلجدار اوكلو ضد اردوغان
كما ذكرتم يبلغ عدد الاكراد في تركيا ما
بين 12 الى 15 مليون مواطن الحزب الذي
يعتبر ذاته ممثلا للاكراد في تركيا حصل في
الانتخابات الاخيره على خمسه ملايين صوت
وهذا يعني ان ليس جميع الناخبين الاكراد
يصوتون وفق معيار الهويه العرقيه بل هناك
هويه الدين وكذلك دوافع اقتصاديه وغيرها
من المعايير التي تحدد توجه الناخب التركي
في عمليه التصويت في مقابل دعم حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي لمرشح المعارضه استطاع تحالف
الشعب وهو الائتلاف الحاكم جذب حزب الدعوه
الحره والمعروف باسم حزب هدى بار الى
تحالفه ويستقطب هدى بار المحافظين الاكراد
ويعتبر من الاحزاب الاسلاميه المتشدده
لكنه لا يحظى بشعبيه حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي رغم ان مرشح المعارضه كمالك
الجدار اوغلو انتزع دعما من حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي لكن كتله القوميين في معسكر
المعارضه ترفض هذا الدعم لانها تراه حزبا
مؤيدا لحزب العمال الكردستاني في المقابل
نال انضمام حزب هدى بار لتحالف الشعب
استياء بسبب تهم تلاحق الحزب بارتكاب
اعمال ارهابيه هي معادله معقده تعكس
اختلاط المصالح والتحالفات في انتخابات
ليست كسابقاتها زيدان زنجلو العربيه
اسطنبول لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج وال
قصصريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على
اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات